a little bit we'll be discussing trade
very much so and lots of other subjects
will be meeting with representatives of
hungry later on with the Prime Minister
and we'll spend some very good time
together so mr. prime minister thank you
very much for being at the White House
yes please thank you very much for the
invitation thank you may I just say here
that we are proud that so many
Hungarians contributed to the tremendous
progress of United States I'm very happy
to be here again may I say to be young
again
20 years ago first time here I have some
expectations for this meeting this
afternoon
first of all to strengthen our strategic
alliance then to discuss global
political issues because so many changes
are going on and we have some similar
approaches and I would like to express
that we are proud to stand together
United States on fighting against the
illegal migration on terrorism and to
protect and help the Christian
communities all around the world so
president thank you very much for the
invitation and you have been great with
respect to Christian communities you
have really put a block up and we
appreciate that very much
so we're gonna have some meetings now a
lot of subjects under discussion and the
relationship is very good with hungry
thank you all very much
well the reaction is very simple China
has been taken advantage of the United
States for many many years I'm not just
talking about during the Obama
administration
you can go back long before that and
it's been taking out 400 500 600 billion
dollars a year out of the United States
and we can't let that happen
we're in a very strong position our
economy has been very powerful theirs
has not been we've gone up a lot since
our great election in 2016 and
if you look at the numbers they've gone
down quite a bit we're dealing with them
we have a very good relationship maybe
something will happen we're gonna be
meeting as you know at the g20 in Japan
and that'll be I think probably a very
fruitful meeting but we're taking in
right now hundreds of billions of
dollars we're taking in billions of
dollars of tariffs and those tariffs are
going to be tremendously if you look at
what we've done thus far with China
we've never taken in $0.10 until I got
elected now we're taking in billions and
billions now it went up as a Friday very
substantially it's 25 percent of 200
billion so now the total is 25 percent
on two hundred and fifty billion dollars
in addition to that we have another
three hundred and twenty five billion
dollars that we can do if we decide to
do it so we are taking in tens of
billions of dollars we've never done
that before with with China we've never
done that before with anybody frankly
because we've been taken advantage of on
all of our trade deals practically this
is a very positive step I love the
position we're in there can be some
retaliation but it can't be a very very
substantial by comparison and out of the
billions of dollars that were taken in a
small portion of that will be going to
our farmers because China will be
retaliating probably to a certain extent
against our farmers we're going to take
the highest year the biggest purchase
that China has ever made with our
farmers which is about 15 billion
dollars and do something reciprocal to
our farmers so our farmers can do well
they'll be planting they'll be able to
sell for less and that'll make the same
kind of money until such time as it's
all straight now so our farmers will be
very happy our manufacturers will be
very happy and our government is very
happy because we're taking in tens of
billions of dollars I think it's working
out very well again we do much less
business with China than they do with us
if you take a look at a hundred billion
versus six hundred billion and just so
you understand
we don't have to pay any tariffs if
you're a manufacturer in this country
you pay nothing open your division or
open up your product have it made in
this country as opposed to made in China
or if you don't want to do that and that
would be the ideal that's what it used
to be a long time ago when we were smart
when we had a economy that was really
something very special now we're having
a period of tremendous growth and
tremendous success like we haven't seen
for a long time but in the old days we
made our product and we took our product
and that's what it was now we go to
China we buy it not anymore
and if they don't want to pay tariffs
make it here or buy it from another
country that's a non-tariff country so
whether you go to Vietnam or so many
others you can do that so the bottom
line is we are taking in tremendous
amounts of money it already started as
of last Friday but a really started
seven months before that it's in the
form of tariffs or taxes and it had a
tremendous impact if you looked at the
first quarter which is always
historically the worst quarter we were
3.2 percent people were very surprised
well a lot of that was the tariffs that
we were taking it from China so we're in
a very good position and I think it's
only going to get better
we're in a great position right now no
matter what we do yeah I think China
wants to have it because companies are
already announcing that they're leaving
China because they can't do that they
can't compete if they're in China with
the tax so what a lot of companies are
going to be doing quite naturally is
leaving China and going to other
countries so they don't have to pay the
tariff that's something that's a problem
for China they don't want to have that
and we don't want to have that
necessarily happen to China but we had a
deal with China it was 95 percent there
and then my representatives as you know
secretary minuchin and Bob Ladouceur
ambassador light Iser they went to China
and they were told the things that were
fully agreed to we're not going to get
any more they're going to uh agree to
them that's not acceptable I said good
that's fine put on the tariffs and again
so we have tens of millions of dollars
pouring into our conference the coffers
of the US Treasury we'll see what
happens with Iran if they do anything it
will be a very bad mistake if they do
anything I'm hearing little stories
about Iran if they do anything they will
suffer greatly we'll see what happens
with the run I'll meet with him directly
yes I'll be meeting with President Xi of
China yes yes I will be meeting with
President Putin also
I think the message is that there has
never been anybody that's been so tough
on Russia but at the same time we're
gonna end up getting along with Russia
it makes sense to get along with Russia
nobody sanctioned Russia like I have
nobody has talked about the pipeline
going to Germany and various other
places like I have I said it's very
unfair having to do with the United
States and NATO has been nobody that's
ever done and if you really look at
something big our energy business we're
now the biggest in the world we're
bigger than Russia we're bigger than
Saudi Arabia we're bigger than anybody
that all happened since I've become
president because I've made it so that
you can do that and we're taking it a
lot of money look our country is doing
really well
we've probably never done this well
before and it's going to continue we
have tremendous signs as far as they
deal with China is concerned believe it
or not it's very important but it's a
very very small part of the kind of
numbers that we're doing right now since
my election I haven't made that decision
yet we have the right to do another 325
billion at 25 percent in additional
tariffs that is a tremendous amount of
money that would come into our country I
have not made that decision yet I don't
know anything about what's going on I
can tell you that there has never been
anybody so transparent as the Trump
administration and it was no collusion
and no obstruction and we're wasting a
lot of time with that stuff but the
Mullen report came out it was a very
good report for us
well people have a lot of respect for
this Prime Minister he's a respected man
and I know he's a tough man but he's a
respected man and he's done the right
thing according to many people on
immigration and you look at some of the
problems that they have in Europe and a
tremendous because they've done it a
different way than the Prime Minister
but I'll let him speak to that question
mr. prime minister from the people by
the people for the people
so it's government which is elected by
the Hungarian people several times so
they're happy to serve our nation we
have a new constitution accepted in 2011
and it's functioning well don't forget
they're a member of NATO and very good
member of NATO and I don't think we can
really go into too much of a discussion
unless that's mentioned yes because
they're asking for things that they're
not entitled to I could ask them I
assume if they asked me I could ask them
for the same kind of thing they wouldn't
want to do it all they're doing is
trying to win an election in 2020 and I
think we're in very good shape we have
the strongest economy we've ever had we
have the single best employment numbers
we've ever had and unemployment numbers
you know it's very interesting but mr.
prime minister as of today we have the
most number of people working in the
United States that we have ever had at
any time in the history of our country
almost 160 million people are working so
that's a big that's a big number I just
saw the final number we're close to 160
million people if you look at
african-american Asian Hispanic
unemployment it's the lowest number it's
ever been so we're doing really well and
all the Democrats want to do is find any
way they can to stop it they're putting
their own personal goals ahead of the
country and you can't do that you just
can't do that and we have a wonderful
Attorney General he's done a very very
good job and I'm sure it'll all work out
well I never did use as you probably
know that's what the molar report was
all about they said no collusion and I
would certainly agree to that I don't
need it
all I need is the opponent said I'm
looking at I'm liking what I see we'll
see what happens it's gonna be a bad
problem for Iran if something happens I
can tell you that they're not going to
be happy they are not gonna be happy
people okay you can figure it out
yourself they know what I mean by it
okay does anybody else have a question
other than these two any questions for
the primary are there any questions for
the prime minister please
the French did a great job and we
appreciate it very much and I've already
communicated that feeling we worked with
them on intelligence and we were able to
get that person back and we thank the
French very much great job I don't want
to I don't want to tell you that now
I'll tell you at some later date I'm
sure okay well it's being devised right
now it's something that has taken place
over the years and if you would like
speak to sonny perdue Department of
Agriculture we love our farmers we take
care of our farmers our farmers have
been incredible no country can get in
the way of our farmers our farmers are
great patriots and they've done a
fantastic job so our farmers are going
to be very well taken care of thank you
all very much